my name is James Cole I'm a medical
laboratory scientist I don't know anyone
who has ever performed patient testing
and reported their results in the
context of the series of mutations and
biodiversity of human tissue types other
medical laboratory scientists use
experimental evidence a biologically
based cause and effect to link what is
known about the difference between
nutrient dependent healthy longevity and
pathology for example after i submitted
the abstract for this poster
presentation an article linked
everything known about quantum physics
to induction of ganado troffer and
releasing hormone messenger RNA
expression could add atropine releasing
hormone or gnrh links all cell type
differentiation in all vertebrates to
all the microRNAs in bull sperm that's
linked to fertility in mammals I don't
think that the authors realize they'd
also linked docosahexaenoic acid and
another fatty acid from micro RNA 9 and
micro RNA 200 to nutrient dependent
transcription factors and human
fertility the transcription factors
linked the development of the olfactory
systems and the immune systems of all
vertebrates to gnrh synthesis in hormone
secreting neurons neurons that secrete
gnrh are linked to every aspect of
nutrient dependent vertebrate
morphological and behavioural diversity
if you only look at the works cited in
this poster session you could link
everything known about nutrient
dependent cell type differentiation to
healthy longevity you could also link
everything known about viruses to all
pathology for example the nematode model
of learning and memory links amino
acid sensing to rna-mediated amino acid
substitutions that protect our organized
genomes from virus driven changes in
nerve cells that alter olfactory acuity
and specificity in Alzheimer's disease
in two weeks Cori Bargmann will receive
an award that links a single neuron to
all works on the lifespan and behavior
of the nematode C elegans that neuron
integrates information from multiple
chemical cues including food oxygen and
pheromones the integration of the hues
controls the expression of social
behavior in the context of changes in pH
she is scheduled to present genes
neurons circuits and behavior an
integrated approach in a compact brain
her work links cell type differentiation
in a compact neuronal system to
everything known to scientists inside
and outside the hospital laboratory many
scientists know how ecological variation
and ecological adaptation link atoms to
ecosystems in all living janeiro for
example food oxygen pH and temperature
linked the nutrient dependent pheromone
controlled physiology of reproduction
from C elegans to the gnrh neuronal
system of all vertebrates all behavior
is linked to super coiled DNA in species
species from microbes to humans super
coiled DNA is the link from rna-mediated
DNA repair two examples of ecological
adaptation in this model the nutrient
dependent micro RNAs linked
energy-dependent changes from hydrogen
atom transfer in DNA base pairs and
solution so the molecular mechanisms
that link morphological and behavioral
phenotypes to survival of the speed
he's via that physiology of reproduction
in the first part of this poster session
six citations like everything known
about nutritional epigenetics from micro
RNAs to rna-mediated amino acid
substitutions the substitutions
differentiate all cell types in all
organized genomes and that is the key to
the link to all living genera fixation
of beneficial amino acid substitutions
in organized genomes links them to
ecological annotation fixation occurs in
the context of the energy dependent
physiology of reproduction in the second
part of the poster for more citations
like virus driven energy theft to all
pathology part 3 links nine more
citations and examples of biologically
based cause and effect from the Zika
virus to differences in human
craniofacial and behavioral phenotypes
the link the key to the model of
nutrient dependent transgenerational
epigenetic inheritance of healthy
longevity compared to Zika virus and
other virus driven pathology is the
energy that is required for rna-mediated
cell type differentiation the Zika virus
and other viruses steal energy that
links odors and the immune system to the
generation or rubble system in all
vertebrates from a single neuron in C
elegans nutrient energy-dependent
prenatal migration of generation neuron
secreting neurons gene are secreting
neurons links the epigenetic effects of
food odors and pheromones to changes in
the hpg and HPA
sees that link hormones to behavior the
energy dependent gnrh pulse modulates
energy-dependent hydrogen atom transfer
in DNA bass player pairs in blood our
blood links what nematodes eat from
their metabolic networks and genetic
networks to the stability of all
organized genomes when the network's
lead to super coiled DNA in all
vertebrates the neurons that secrete
gnrh link metabolic networks to genetic
networks during the concurrent
maturation of the neuroendocrine
reproductive and central nervous systems
the gnrh neuronal system can be compared
to a single neuron in C elegans because
gnrh links the physiology of
reproduction sex differences in behavior
and other behavioral differences that
link rna-mediated amino acid
substitutions to morphological
phenotypes and behavioral phenotypes for
example what nematodes eat links the
behavior of C elegans to the behavior of
P pacificus a predatory nematode with
teeth I've added quotations from
Schrodinger Phillip ball and Bruce
McEwen at the bottom of the poster I
hope their works will encourage others
to learn more about the anti-entropic
energy of the Sun and how it links light
and energy to the bio physically
constrained chemistry of protein folding
protein folding starts with epigenetic
effects on genes that are linked to
effects on behavior in the context of
the system biology represented in this
model in the early 1990s I learned to
differentiate between the effects on
hormones and the effects
of hormones on behavior that led me to
link the sun's virus idol energy from UV
light to super coil DNA which protects
organized genomes from virus driven
entropy from the perspective the physics
higher animals metabolize food and they
return the degraded forms of food which
are the power supply that links soil
bacteria to the growth of plants but
sunlight is a source of the
anti-entropic energy in plants the
quantized and nature of light and energy
links all of Einstein's theories to
chemistry quantum physics explains how
matter and light interact which most
people can link to the reasons why grass
is green and the sky is blue medical
laboratory scientists know that the
nature of light and energy is also
measured in the spectroscopic methods
that enable us to decode the structures
of molecules which link hydrogen atom
transfer in DNA base pairs to the
visible spectrum of light but also to UV
light and infrared light in the context
of light chemistry and molecular
epigenetics molecular laboratory
scientists learn the difference between
an effect on their test results and an
effect on their behavior the epigenetic
effects of the sons biological energy
are linked to effects on behavior in all
living genera by supercoiled DNA that
protects organized genomes from virus
driven entropy